now now I don't wanna do it
of course of course of course the
greatest game of all time gets a sequel
the Japanese name is car - let's go to
Hawaii
I mean translated but really it's mr.
mosquito - I'm so [ __ ] excited I'm
sweating I'm literally dripping in sweat
okay so we can choose said Japanese or
ah race so even Japanese people came
races this is great everyone knows that
America is wearing bandannas and
sunglasses yes
the Brown's daughter Aerith shall be
your first we're going right for the
daughter I like it how can they not
speak English English for six years yeah
how can they not speak English they're
just shy they say that the Japanese are
timid but after six years you'd think
they would have learned something
what a mean [ __ ] make fun of people
Aris oh god what is that
[Music]
yeah America America suck blood suck the
blood for a miracle yeah we're gonna
soak that [ __ ] where the [ __ ] are we
gonna attack
what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] talking
about oh there it is there it is ah
picks out that booty how do we engage
stop moving
yeah I don't care oh god oh god that's
oh they took away that annoying knock
back effects dealer Oh what who wakes up
like that that's [ __ ] haha that's
terrifying I'm sorry
this game is [ __ ] hardcore as [ __ ]
fight me ah how do i I don't under what
is that oh oh oh oh we got a lick how do
wait whoa Jess that's my [ __ ] take it
video games
I'll show you video games oh yeah oh I'm
hitting all their sweet spots yeah
that's right relax
sorry alright let's suck this [ __ ] up
Wow okay this [ __ ] better what now oh
god okay hey Oh what oh I see oh it
looks like a little nipples
that's disgusting but
[Music]
oh yeah look at that sweet look a nice
sweet [ __ ] I own swag what I can't
penetrate damn it I can't penetrate her
no oh right in the boob
hey the boobs jiggle in this game that's
great improvements haha I don't give you
each you going you going dad stop being
itchy then Jesus Christ every time oh I
also we can suck in it right now
side boob suckage nice yes suck that
side boob for America we did it but
Jesus Christ how much how much blood
every supposed to take we're too heavy
oh look at us which fat now are we
supposed to dispose it somewhere I don't
fight off oh yeah
oh we're supposed to fly there don't
kill me don't kill me don't kill me girl
don't keep me we're going home stage
clear hi fibrosis yeah America
I see a member I love this game this
game's art look at those hands
terrifying side chest ooh double biceps
back oh whoa let's sing the [ __ ] out of
this guy
oh god this guy means business what
where has this game been all my life
it's so [ __ ] good it's a bodybuilding
champion awesome so excuse me but what
the [ __ ] is that what in the heaven's
name is that ooh
let's get him now let's get him now
right in the armpit nice oh yeah through
the leg ahh why I don't understand
rest in peace shut up whoa hello oh my
god that's terrifying
go to sleep muscle man fights those ABS
what just happened
okay glows on his ass so I'm gonna
assume we have to do the ass game is
classy as [ __ ] oh of course
right [ __ ] there huh that was
necessary right so what the I don't
understand I'm so [ __ ] lost I sucks
five tanks of blood are you [ __ ]
kidding me
[Music]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what
hope you enjoyed this video they were
like we did and I will
mmm-hmm suck em some more been in the
next one say awesome
[Music]